l'année politique débute en janvier par
la tenue du premier conseil
communautaire d'un saint quentin en
yvelines dorénavant composé de douze
communes au revoir la casse qui est
bonjour à sky michel laugier maire
divers droite de montigny le bretonneux
conserve la présidence
c'est une nouvelle aventure parce que
c'est déjà un nouveau territoire c'est
un nouveau territoire avec d'autres
enjeux ont gardé tout simplement
aujourd'hui nous avions trois gars sur
le territoire nous adorons cette nous
avons c'est désormais une nouvelle
aventure qui débute mal avec une
opposition de gauche qui refuse de
prendre part aux premiers votes
s'estimant exclus de la gouvernance les
tensions se poursuivront tout au long de
l'année
la détention également entre le
département des yvelines et l'état les
élus du conseil départemental engage un
bras de fer avec le gouvernement
suite à la diminution des dotations
versées une diminution de 288 millions
d'euros en septembre une manifestation
avait lieu devant l'assemblée nationale
ce sont des sommes absolument
considérable que l'état ne nous donne
plus alors que il décide de nos dépenses
les dépenses sociales et ils ne
compensent pas alors que normalement il
a cette obligation constitutionnelle
face à des ressources en chute les
yvelines tente de se rapprocher des
hauts de seine pour mutualiser les
moyens en juin un premier budget commun
été votée 2017 sera une année électorale
chargée entre présidentielle
sénatoriales et les législatives et les
différentes campagnes ont débuté dès
cette année la primaire de la droite et
du centre a vu la victoire de françois
fillon 1 françois fillon largement en
tête également dans les yvelines avec +2
66% à de la primaire on retiendra
également la candidature du député
yvelinois président du parti chrétien
démocrate jean frédéric poisson
inconnu du grand public il a marqué les
débats avec des prises de positions sur
plusieurs sujets de société et c'est
pendant cette primaire à droite que
c'est préparer la primaire de la gauche
verdict en janvier 2010 est un yvelinois
est là aussi en course benoît hamon
députés socialistes en campagne
il poursuit sa critique du gouvernement
qu'il a quitté en 2014
enfin 2016 aura été marqué sur saint
quentin en yvelines par deux départs de
mer en mars c'était un lynchage qui pour
des raisons de santé les scénes et les
du tube prendre la tête de l'une des
dernières villes communistes d'île de
france
comme toujours dans ce moment là on
espère que
les choses vont s'améliorer s'arranger
c'est pas tout à fait le kg
la situation de santé encore besoin
d'attention de soins en octobre françois
de ligne et maire ps de guyancourt
depuis quatorze ans passés lui la main à
marie christine le tarnec
une décision qu'il dit avoir prise afin
de préparer l'avenir